the cost of living is spiraling many
consumers are looking for ways to
stretch their money or put off paying
their bills a bit longer
clarner clearpay affirm zip and zilch
are just some of the fintechs that are
offering shoppers the option to pay in
instalments at the point of sale you see
when a customer uses buy now pay later
as a payment option the bmpl provider
foots most of the bill
the customer then pays back the bmpl
provider in say three to four
instalments some bmpl apps make money by
charging retailers a small fee some also
charge consumers late fees but they
don't typically charge interest the part
of our business is about making things
slightly more affordable because we
don't charge interest
um when consumers you know compare and
are going to see increasing rates on the
credit cards i think our products may
become even more attractive
in 2021 the value of bnpl payments
reached 120 billion dollars by 2026 it's
expected to hit
576 billion dollars but in 2022 and the
financial downturn has shaken the bmpl
industry rising interest rates eat into
the margins of bmpl firms and harder
economic times means more of their loans
to customers go bad so bmpl companies
end up burning through their cash
reserves and borrowing more at the same
time bmpl companies have been under
scrutiny about whether they've been good
for consumers bnpl companies have
targeted a younger generation of
shoppers particularly
young women through partnering with fast
fashion retailers and showcasing
lifestyle content on social media bmpl
became a float to pay for things you
didn't know you needed but there's been
a vibe shift with 1 in 12 people turning
to bmpl to cover basic costs such as
food and toiletries this is for the
people that are running low on groceries
and running low on funds there is apps
called a quad pay chlorina um a firm
they are also facing scrutiny from
lawmakers and regulators at the moment
bnpl payments aren't regulated in the uk
please bring in a cap on the cost of all
credit so that we make sure that some of
those new fintechs the buy now pay
laters of this world are not the kinds
of financial companies that we get
coming to our shores to exploit our
constituents yet again citizens advice
has likened bmpl credit to quicksand
more than 40 of users are borrowing
money to make their bnpl payments all
adds up to you know this very long term
issue which
can spiral really quickly when you then
start receiving you know angry letters
and phone calls and whatnot not knowing
much about credit
i just kind of you know buried my head
in the sand which is the absolute worst
thing to do in a proposed plan to
tighten rules lenders will have to make
sure that loans are affordable and that
advertising is fair and not misleading
despite the challenges the space remains
vibrant more merchants are signing on to
offer the service and big tech
challenger banks and wall street are
flocking into the space
buy now pay later
isn't going anywhere
[Music]
you